تزامن انتهاء الشهر الاول من المواجهات
المسلحه في السودان بين الجيش والدعم
السريع مع اصدار رئيس مجلس السياده قائد
الجيش عبد الفتاح البرهان سلسله قرارات
اقاله لعدد من المسؤولين الحكوميين
والعسكريين وتعيين اخرين بدلا منهم ابرز
تلك القرارات اقاله محافظ بنك السودان
المركزي حسين يحيى جنقول وتعيين برع
الصديق علي احمد بدلا منه متبعا ذلك بقرار
تجميد حسابات قوات الدعم السريع وشركاتها
في جميع البنوك في السودان وفروعها في
الخارج ومنع صرف اي استحقاقات ماليه
مرصوده لها كما اصدر البرهان قرارا باحاله
اربعه ضباط كبار في الجيش على التقاعد
وذلك لعدم استجابتهم لقرار سابق لقائد
الجيش بانهاء كل انتدابات القوات النظاميه
داخل تشكيلات الدعم السريع ومن ابرز هؤلاء
الض قائد العمليات في الدعم السريع اللواء
عثمان حامد رئيس وفد التفاوض عن الدعم
السريع في جده العميد عمر حمدان ومدير
مكتب حميدتي اللواء حسن محجوب الاقالات
امتدت لتشمل مدير عام الشرطه وزير
الداخليه المكلف عنان حامد وتعيين الفريق
خالد حسان محي الدين بدلا منه قرارات
البرهان تضمنت ايضا انهاء خدمه كل من
السفير السابق في برلين عبد المنعم البيتي
والمتحدث السابق باسم الخارجيه السودانيه
السفير حيدر بدوي من العمل في وزاره
الخارجيه في حين بدا لافتا ان قرارات رئيس
مجلس السياده لم تتضمن اقاله نائبه في
المجلس قائد قوات الدعم السريع محمد حمدان
حماتي او حل قواته